dr. terence moore is a highly
accomplished man a former lieutenant in
the United States Marine Corps he
received a PhD in history from the
University of Edinburgh served as a
principal the top classical charter
school in Colorado like dr. Bob
mentioned is an advisor for hillsdale's
Barney charter school initiative and
most recently published a novel about
boyhood baseball and his home state of
Texas during my two and a half years at
Hillsdale I've taken several classes
with dr. Moore every meeting he led us
through lively discussions drawing
students into the text inviting us to
dwell with the best thinkers political
actors theologians philosophers who have
ever been studying their understanding
of human nature and man's responsibility
in history he walked us through the
pilgrims path in Augustine's City of God
and taught Lincoln's Gettysburg Address
as the greatest American poem by tracing
the ideas throughout the western
heritage he showed me the power of ideas
and that ideas have consequences it is
now my privilege to introduce to you dr.
Terrence more
thank you miss willoughby are y'all
doing all right survive the weather of
the inauguration and other various and
sundry aspects of DC okay well just get
round right down to it one of my
favorite philosophers Adam Smith in a
very famous book launch the discipline
known then as political economy and that
we now call economics with the aid of a
single simple object a pen by showing
how the division of labor produced
40,000 times the number of pins a single
person could make in a day he proved
that the combined effects of millions of
people all following their enlightened
self-interest and natural talents in the
making and exchanging of goods were
superior to the top down direction of
the ridiculous Imperial economic system
known as mercantilism now though I'm not
nearly the genius that Adam Smith was
despite this Malika's very kind comments
I hope at least to be able to shed light
on the workings of what I shall call
civil society with an illustration
almost as basic the clothing closet the
clothing closet at a charter school I
ran in Colorado was not an actual closet
it was rather a collection of you school
uniforms that were put on sale about
once a month that steeply discounted
prices the sources the source of the
uniforms was simply children outgrowing
them and their parents donating the
general supply of clothes all sorts of
families got their children's clothes at
the clothing closet rich middle-income
and poor as fast as children shoot
through clothes particularly in
elementary school there is no shame and
not wanting to lay out a lot of money
for things your children may be wearing
only for a few months furthermore those
families who were known to be poor
qualifying for free and reduced lunch in
bureaucratic terms were provided with
school uniforms from the clothing closet
for free so the greater economy in the
purchase of school clothing at the
school Oh to a series of decisions and
activities the policy of the score
requiring the children to wear uniforms
in the first place rather than having
the halls turn into a high-pressure and
expensive fashion show the adopting of a
reasonable uniform that could be
purchased in expensive
it stores like target and kohls who are
sponsoring this program today by the way
the willingness of families to donate
their children's clothes once they had
outgrown them the volunteer spirit of a
few mothers who were willing to manage
the clothing closet keeping the
administration that is me as far out of
it as possible and the discretion of one
person working at the school who knew
all the poorer families and would supply
them with what they needed so that's how
it worked and the families loved it when
you think about it the clothing closet
was simply an extension of what goes on
in homes any second or third or fourth
child of the same sex is usually wearing
things that have been worn worn before
it should not surprise us that the word
economy economics and economize come
from the Greek word boyko sore EKOS
which means family the family the basic
unit of society is best run economically
besides that there is more care and
compassion shown in the home than in
government run programs economy and true
compassion those are virtues worth
having well what happens when
governments get involved in school
clothing you may think they don't but
there are currently two states i can
find west virginia and michigan where
Hillsdale colleges that do have school
clothing allowances for the poor one
state senator in Michigan in 2011 tried
to require those receiving the funds to
shop at thrift stores and he was nearly
burned at the stake realize that this is
a program that other states don't even
have but that didn't stop NPR from
getting involved and you may know that
federal stimulus money was handed out in
some states for back-to-school shopping
I have an article here detailing how New
York George Soros added 35 million of
his own to the 140 140 million dollar
handout that had to be spent before the
funds expired in 2009 two hundred
dollars per child we were told magically
appear that's not those are not my words
but the reporters magically appeared on
the benefit cards of those receiving
welfare or food stamps it's free money
said one of the recipients of the no
strings attached hand out thank God for
Obama he's looking out for us the state
of New Mexico also used stimulus funds
in 2011 for a school clothing
European countries do this regular
regularly so why shouldn't the US this
may seem far-fetched but we are in the
second term of Obama if we go this way
don't be surprised if jay-z and Beyonce
come out with a new line of designer
jeans that somehow are paid for that
with that $200 what's wrong with sharing
a little back-to-school wealth well
economically and politically there are a
few things the stimulus money or any
other such funds had to travel through
what Reagan called the puzzle palace on
the Potomac and as you know and as
Reagan also said somewhere there must be
some overhead the stimulus itself does
not seem to me to be constitutional what
I tend to be a literalist on these
matters and the stimulus money or any
taxes imposed to provide for school
clothing or free school lunches which
Milton Friedman said do not exist
undisputedly undisputedly takes money
out of the private sector in further
further derails economic recovery but I
wish to hone in on a different aspect of
the problem such federal programs
inhibit the activity of what we might
call civil society civil society is a
vital term for a free people one not
often used today so I'll try to explain
it civil society in the primary sense is
the equivalent of We the People the
American people preceded the government
in fact the American people constituted
the government and the American people
to this day hold the government
accountable or at least are supposed to
civil society then I ranges government
in such a way to accomplish certain
defined ends and works through
government to achieve those ends in
President Reagan's formulation we are a
nation that has a government not the
other way around government of course is
divided into both different branches in
different levels to attend to the
different offices of government to
affect greater energy inefficiency and
to prevent consolidation of excessive
governmental power that is all pretty
straightforward although I must say the
ability of most modern office holders to
articulate these basic constitutional
principles is minimal not all office
hole
but but many of them at any rate the
activity of civil society does not stop
at government the American people also
work through what we might call the
economy which has a natural system of
cause and effect based upon both human
beings need for basic necessities but
also on their innate desire to create
things and to truck barter in exchange
one thing for another and we know or
ought to know that the government must
be both strong and efficient for the
economy to work well and that when
government exceeds its warrant the
economy is undermined but there is a
third realm of human activity through
which the American people work to
achieve certain ends this arena I do not
have a good name for so I shall call it
also civil society just like the first
civil society this arena may involve
government activity mainly at the local
level and it may involve economic
exchange yet it is neither primarily
political nor economic what I have in
mind are people working together largely
outside of government at least outside
of the federal government to solve their
problems and make their lives better
civil society in this sense does not
exclude actions of government yet when
civil society is robust and effective
most affairs are taken care of without
direct governmental assistance or
alternatively with government operating
at the lowest and most accountable level
possible and with the least bureaucracy
possible now professors get paid to
throw around a lot of celebrated names
and abstruse books whenever they get
into a jam so that's what I'm going to
do now for civil society in the first
sense I invoke John Locke the coming
together of a people to secure life
liberty and property for government I
mean the Constitution and it's exegesis
in the Federalist by economy I mean what
Adam Smith detailed in his inquiry into
the nature and causes of the wealth of
nations and by civil society in the
second sense i refer mostly to what
Tocqueville called associations in his
second volume of democracy in America
Tocqueville claims that the flourishing
of associations is vital to maintaining
freedom in Adam
Corsi in fact he goes so far as saying
that the science of associations is the
mother of all sciences in a democracy
and he further argues that if a
democracy were to lead lose its genius
for creating associations in ordinary
life not just freedom but civilization
itself would be in peril I went to dwell
on this realm of the American people's
civil life today not only because it is
the least talked about but also because
i believe the progressive assault on
civil society is ultimately the most
unamerican part of their agenda and will
have the most destructive consequences
if that agenda is not squashed to better
illustrate the workings of civil society
I shall call on two important figures in
American history who understood the
thriving of free associations Benjamin
Franklin and Ronald Reagan Benjamin
Benjamin Franklin may be the most
astonishing figure in American history
how many of you were Benjamin Franklin
fans okay it should be all of you you're
not convinced of that I shall convince
you of this shortly franklin had only
two years of formal education but
acquired a rigorous self education and
history philosophy and essay writing all
undertaken in a spare time while working
for his father as a candle maker and
later for his older brother in a print
shop by the time he was 16 he had
tricked his brother into publishing his
own series of essays that is Franklin
series of essays under the pseudonym
silence do-good in one of the four
newspapers in the colonies that series
became the first such endeavor in
American literature one of the essays
was a satire on Harvard College another
contemplated establishing an insurance
fund for the relief of widows now my
guess is there were not too many 16 year
old boys looking out for the welfare of
widows in the entire english-speaking
world in the 18th century also at the
age of 16 Franklin ended up running the
entire paper when his brother was thrown
in jail for opposing the colonial
administration in Boston the
responsibility went to his head he
quarreled with his brother and that
quarrel led to the 17 year olds leaving
Boston violating his terms of indenture
and arriving disheveled in Philadelphia
with no contacts no prospects only a
Dutch dollar to his name Franklin
humorously described a scene of his
arrival in the city where he would make
his mark in his autobiography perhaps
not as obvious as how dishevelled and
unformed though full of life and
opportunity the town of Philadelphia
must have been before Franklin's living
there beginning as an employee in a
print shop Franklin after a two-year
trip to London ended up owning his own
printing press a newspaper by the time
he was 24 he worked tirelessly and not
impressed with the theological bickering
of the time and disappointed that his
church did not preach the value of good
morals the young man conceived quote the
bold and arduous project of arriving at
moral perfection Franklin created his
own moral system not surprisingly
emphasizing the virtues of Industry in
ferg allottee and resolution oh and yes
chastity but he was pragmatic on the
virtue of chastity insisting that one
should use venery rarely and only for
health or offspring and never to the
injury of one's or another's one's own
or another's reputation now depending on
how much rarely means and how much
venery is needed for health we can say
that Franklin was as good as his word at
least in not harming another's
reputation we still don't know who this
mother of his oldest son William was
Franklin was not an ordinary printer he
did not just print useful publications
he went out of his way to entertain and
to instruct the public his popular Poor
Richard's Almanac is a good example in
addition to providing the farming
community with useful information about
the weather and planting he filled the
Almanac with amusing moral Maxim's such
as lost found lost time is never found
again there are no gains without pains
you thought that was original did you
know early to bed early to rise makes a
man healthy wealthy and wise tis hard
for an empty sack to stand upright
creditors have better memories than
debtors
and my favorite dust thou love life then
do not waste time for time is the stuff
that life is made of these may sound
like common places but presumably the
avid readers of Franklin's Almanac plied
their children at the appropriate
moments with these sayings his final
compilation of these Maxim's were put in
in the form of father Abraham speech at
the auction otherwise known as the way
to wealth it was printed throughout
Europe and America what we must realize
is that Franklin was not just printing
an almanac he was shaping the American
character while Franklin was
establishing himself as a printer in
writer he also found time for public
projects many of these were an extension
of his own spirit of self-improvement
and curiosity in all things human and
natural the most important of these was
perhaps the junto a group of young
tradesmen who were like Franklin
establishing themselves in business in
the community they got together
regularly to discuss topics on any point
of morals politics and natural
philosophy that is science questions
included topics such as why do forms on
the outside of tankards containing cold
water during the summer weather
emigration of servants increases the
wealth of a country whether there should
be an insurance fund for servants
there's that topic of insurance again
and what constitutes the happiness of a
rational creature in other words these
young working men in their spare time
were undertaking a college education we
might add without a federal student loan
program since the junto is both a small
Society for self improvement in a means
of local improvement Franklin helped
improve the world around him many of his
civic minded projects had their origin
in the junto most notably the formation
of the first lending library in the
colleagues began as the gin toes need
for books and Franklin's design to make
them more available to pour in younger
folks that institution was copied
throughout the colonies the formation of
the first fire company began as Franklin
began as Franklin's writing articles on
the brave men who fight fires and the
means of preventing fires after a paper
given in the junto the fur
the first fire company was formed making
Philadelphia after time and with much
more reiteration of the fire company in
Franklin's view probably better than any
city in the world in putting out fires a
spirit of civic duty led to the saving
of life and property Franklin was a
veritable industry of institutional
foundation in reform he started the
Pennsylvania militia without support
from the assembly he set up an academy
that served as the embryo of the
University of Pennsylvania he initiated
the first attempt at colonial Union in
response to tensions between France and
England that was called the Albany Union
for which he designed the first truly
American political cartoon a severed
snake with the caption join or die he
improved the cyllage city watch of
Philadelphia he initiated the paving of
the streets of Philadelphia he reformed
the colonial post office and helped
establish the Continental post office he
founded the american philosophical
society he launched a hospital for the
poor and he was the moving force behind
erecting a large Hall to accommodate the
preaching of the evangelist George
Whitfield which later served both the
Academy he founded and as a gathering
place for religious speakers of any
religious denomination these
institutions led to his own improvement
in the improvement of civil society not
one of these institutions came as a
directive from England least of all from
the british ministry or local colonial
officials Franklin got on well with the
leading lights of the Scottish and
English enlightenment but not so much
with governments and when Franklin went
to England he was you he was usually the
one being consulted for example on
setting up lightning rods are improving
the street lights of London moreover
what is important to know is that as
busy as he was Franklin mastered all of
these enterprises he thought about them
when he undertook to the project of
setting up an English school for example
he read the leading philosophers of the
day on the topic and quoted them
extensively and his two lengthy and
detailed essays on the subject now I've
read these essays dozens of times and
they're still wonderful in fact the
schools that we're talking about setting
up if you don't know if you want to know
what they look like reed franklin that's
what they are we're not inventing
inventing anything new
Franklin understood how institutions
worked and he explained them to people
he did not just spout platitudes about
needing better schools for Philadelphia
to give children critical thinking
skills so they could get good jobs in an
18th century global economy he worked
out a school from top to bottom
including the books that would be read
by the children Franklin's various civic
activities improved the lives of those
around them he was also instrumental in
shaping the American character Franklin
once said in an essay that an American
is not known for who he is for who he is
that is what his name is or what his
patrimony is or what social station he
comes from rather an American is known
for what he can do Franklin was living
proof that the son of a candle maker
with lots of drive and a love of his
fellow man and obviously genius despair
could with the help of other like-minded
people accomplish wonders many of those
accomplishments were in politics and in
economics Franklin was obviously
indispensable in renat winning the
revolution as early as 1729 he wrote an
essay on the need for a paper currency
in America yet the charge of the
marxists that Franklin was simply the
embodiment of the bourgeois materialist
is not true because of Franklin's
enterprise scientific inquiry
sociability and constant quest to
improve the world around him at the time
of his death in 1790 the people of
Philadelphia were not only freer and
wealthier than they had been before his
arrival 67 years before they were also
better read more educated safer from
fires more cared for one sick less dusty
warmer in the winter better able to see
an old age safer from lightning more
informed about the world more
entertained more given to civic minded
projects of all kinds friendlier and
more in touch with their neighboring
states and more confident in themselves
than they had been before this runaway
Prentice showed up in their town one
more consideration is it an accident
that virtually no regular public school
in the country still requires its
student
to read Franklin's autobiography is this
not something of a national oversight
everybody used to read Franklin's
autobiography we turn now to Ronald
Reagan it seems to me vital to this
nation that we get the Reagan's story
right in Reagan we have the lesson the
proof that the American experiment in
self-government works moreover it did
not just work in the old horse and buggy
days before big cities before running
water before computers as the
progressive left would have you believe
the American experiment in Liberty and
self-government in free markets and a
vibrant civil society works in the age
of cities in the millions of man making
it to the moon of television and
computers it is the progressive
experiment that does not work in the
modern or any other age and it leaves
everything behind it in shambles
particularly the vitality of civil
society to understand Reagan in his
faith in America we have to turn we do
have to turn back the clock a little to
take a look at the world he grew up in
here's Reagan with nearly 10,000 people
Dixon was more than ten times larger
than Tampico we arrived there in 1920
when I was nine years old and to me it
was heaven Dixon had a busy Main Street
line with shops several churches an
elementary in a high school a public
library a post office a wire screen
factory a shoe factory and a cement
plant at the outskirts of town dairy
farms stretch as far as you could see it
was a small universe where I learned
standards and values that would guide me
for the rest of my life almost everybody
knew one another and because they knew
one another they tended to care about
each other if the family down the street
had a crisis a death or serious illness
a neighbor brought them dinner that
night if a farmer lost his barn to a
fire his friends would pitch in and help
him rebuild it at church you prayed side
by side with your neighbors and if
things were going wrong for them you
prayed for them and knew they prayed for
you if things went wrong for you the
scene of small town America in the early
20th century comes straight from
Reagan's
autobiography and it was etched in his
memory his whole life but there were
other memories he had of Dixon these
memories came from the beginning of the
breakdown of civil society or near
breakdown and that breakdown did not
take place in the cities or among them
racial minority it came in small-town
Midwestern America you see Reagan's
father is one of the few Democrats in
Dixon was appointed head of the New Deal
programs for the area and was eventually
in charge of the WPA while in college
Reagan remembers visiting his father at
the government office and seeing men who
had worked their whole lives standing in
line for relief relief funds and
supplies they were clearly dispirited
you could read it in their eyes and in
the way that they stood a working man
himself Reagan's father knew how
important a job is not just for a man's
material well-being but for what we
would now casually dismiss and pseudo
Freudian terms as his ego his sense of
pride and self-worth so the father got
these men little odd jobs around the
county that made the men feel like they
were doing something for their relief
checks they were grateful they stood
taller but then the men stopped coming
for those jobs he asked why it was
because they were told by other relief
agencies that they would lose their
benefits if it looked like they had a
job when Reagan's father was appointed
to administer the WPA a little bit later
the men again stopped signing up as they
had at first because the welfare arm of
the New Deal came into town and told the
men that they did not need the WPA to
get direct benefits the men were caught
between the rival bureaucracies trying
to protect each trying to protect its
own turf now that is a part of the noon
the new deal that we were not told about
in the history books we were told that
FDR said let there be government jobs
and there were government jobs we're not
told that the leading jobs program the
New Deal was undermined by the welfare
part of the bureaucracy trying to keep
itself alive for Reagan it was never the
job so much as the human cost of large
governmental projects those men and
Dixon fortunately had enough spirit left
in them to go back to job
whenever they finally became available
not really until after the war but
Reagan knew that the Great Society would
undermine the very basis of civil
society the desire of a man to make
something of himself and to provide for
those he loves Reagan understood that
the basis of civil society is the family
and that nothing should be more
protected by government than the family
yet it was precisely the family that big
government liberals were trying to
undermine or were undermining whether
intentionally or not in a crucial part
of his 1964 televised address on behalf
of very Goldwater Reagan told a story of
a woman who had come before a judge the
woman had six children and was on her
seventh about to have it she wanted to
divorce her husband not because they had
a falling out but because she could get
more aid from the aid to dependent
children program then her husband made
at his job the idea came from two other
women in her neighborhood instead of
women in the neighborhood pitching in to
help each other out under the old model
of civil society they were coming up
with ways to trick the system there was
the genesis of the breakdown of the
family in the 20th century Regan Reilly
remarked yet any time you and I question
the schemes of the do-gooders we're
denounced as being against their
humanitarian goals they say we were
always against things never for anything
well the trouble with our liberal
friends is not that they are ignorant
it's just that they know so much that
isn't so yet Reagan was not just a
critic of the failures of the welfare
state though he was that he was also the
muse of civil society when it worked as
it should one thing we were rarely told
about Reagan in our school in college
classrooms also concerns the breakdown
of civil society this time during the
60s specifically the youth movement
we're told that the hippies marched for
civil rights and against a war that
could not be one we're not told about
the violence the mobs the plots to kill
federal judges just as we were not told
that the communist plot to take over
Hollywood was real in that when Reagan
had to in the in the Hollywood Issue
Reagan had to carry a gun and was
shadowed by a federal agent because
insurgents into a Hollywood Union
threatened to
acid into his face at any rate Reagan
there in the 60s was right there in the
middle of it as governor of California
and he saw the fundamental breakdown of
one aspect of civil society the very
basic social practice of young people
listening to and taking advice from
older wiser people how many people in
this room think that that's a good thing
to happen okay younger people you're
supposed to raise your hands to Reagan
actually talked to young people he made
fun of them when he needed to saying
that those who carried make love not war
signs look like they couldn't do much of
either and a host of other things that
were also funny but he also told moving
stories of the men of his generation to
explain that generation to the young if
they were listening and he also could
see that not every young person in
America was a rioter of what he called
the half torch will travel variety
here's one moving description of a young
man in action given by Reagan when he
was speaking as own College Eureka in
1967 some time ago in Newport California
a row of luxurious oceanfront homes were
threatened by an abnormally high tide
and heavy surf all through the day and
night volunteers worked piling sandbags
in an effort to save these homes local
TV stations aware of the drama covered
the struggle it was about 2 a.m. when
one newscaster grabbed a young fellow in
his teens a tired only in wet trunks he
had been working all day and night one
of several hundred of his age group no
he did not live in one of the homes that
they were trying to save and yes he was
cold and tired the newscaster inevitably
got around to wine the answer was so
poignant such an indictment of so many
of us it should be on a billboard across
the nation he said well I guess it's the
first time we've ever felt like we were
needed what Reagan is describing their
two young people at his own college was
not a federal program or an ambitious
Ivy League graduate padding his resume
at a non-profit before moving on to a
career in politics what he was described
is the good in all of us the spirit that
made America great this is the spirit
Reagan stood for and spent his entire
life trying to rekindle some may not
realize that his first speech he gave at
GE and as a goodwill ambassador during
touring plants around the country
consisted in remarks he made about a
local charitable event in which he
distinguished between private charities
on the one hand and government programs
that spent two dollars for every dollar
that the people actually got who were
supposed to be supported the people at
that gathering liked his remarks so much
that his hand shaking and meet and greet
tours turn into a formal speech making
effort at both GE and local
organizations where he extolled the
virtues of private initiative in matters
of local concern and the failure of
government in matters of local concern
not surprisingly when he left office 25
years later after having brought about
the Reagan Revolution one of the
statistics he liked quoting even more
than the 19 million jobs created even
more than inflation going from fourteen
percent to one percent was the nearly
sixty percent rise in charitable giving
in the 50 million American Americans
working for or giving to private
charities these were not just statistics
for Reagan behind every new job there
was a man or woman who could walk with
his head held high behind each dip in
inflation there were millions of
families who could plan for the future
and behind each charitable donation
there was a good heart willing to give
there is a reason why I'm talking about
Franklin and Reagan in this dismal
political and economic time in our
nation's history it is not to dwell on
in particular policy that they advocated
nor winning political strategy that they
conceived it is because Franklin and
Reagan were America's best teachers on
the strengths of a vibrant civil society
neither one of them looked at politics
from the perspective of a Beltway they
looked at political life from the
perspective of towns and neighborhoods
family work neighborhood peace and
freedom were the five powerful words
Reagan invoked in his acceptance speech
in 1980 when the country was in economic
turmoil and
suffering from our current president
lectured us malaise in being a great
teacher Reagan did John just throw
statistics at us nor platitudes he told
stories just as Franklin had told
stories in his newspaper stories that
both amused and instructed because they
rang true in the human heart we began
this talk by saying something about
school clothing allowances we think it
is a bad idea least I do we think it is
unconstitutional we think it is a
transparent buying of votes but not
everyone sees it that way and not only
those who are receiving the handouts
someone must tell the other side of the
story and that side of the story cannot
be told until we remember what civil
society is supposed to look like and how
our cities and towns are rapidly losing
that memory not too long ago a small
group of public spirited men and women
with whom Hillsdale College is working
in setting up a charter school in a poor
neighborhood in one of the historic
countries of historic cities of this
country went to a town meeting to hear
people offer their comments on the
opening of the school many of the people
who came to the meeting did not want the
school in their neighborhood now that's
not terribly disturbing because wherever
you put schools in this great land
people always come out and say they
don't want them they fear the traffic
and all the congestion that schools will
create more telling was what one woman
said at the meeting who lived in this
neighborhood she asked the Planning
Board in the crowd at large who would
want to set up a good school in this
neighborhood who would want to set up a
good school in this neighborhood and
that question told the whole story not
only did the people in that neighborhood
in this great country not know how to
set up a school themselves something
that every little outpost in America
used to be able to do they cannot even
imagine anyone ever wanting to do that
for them or to do that with them which
is even more important or the
two-hundred-dollar clothing allowance is
going to buy back the lost knowledge of
self-government and the lost faith and
the one thing that people have have to
believe in themselves I don't think so
well where to start well what I would
like to see or some statesmen and other
public figures who stopped trying to
guess what rib the electorate wants
tickled and start trying to tell the
stories that are plain to see in the
country today and I would like more set
about what we used to call civil society
it is as though at every election we
agree to a silly division of labor in
and who gets to talk about what the
Republicans get to talk about the
economy and only the economy and they
usually do so in numbers that do not
register in human terms while the
Democrats get to talk about everything
else the universities and the schools
and scientific research that they fund
to get the results that they want and
they get to talk about the culture at
large the Republicans look like they are
rich and only interested in material
things the Democrats look broad-minded
and multifaceted what would such a new
rhetoric look like which is really an
old rhetoric well I am not exactly sure
I think it would tell stories about what
this country once looked like when
people were self-governing not as an
historical exercise but as an indication
of what it can be again and where civil
societies is still thriving those
stories should be told to but I think
such a message might begin what I with
what I call the aggressive Socratic mode
miss Willa key knows about will it be
knows about the aggressive Socratic mode
I think it is height it is high time
that these high-minded supposedly
intellectual types the Sophists really
really be asked a few questions so that
they would be forced as Reagan said to
tell us the score once in a while those
questions might include the following
mr. president just over four years ago
you inspired the American people with
the phrase yes we can and that is a true
American sentiment but mr. president you
played a little rhetorical trick on us
you never told us who the we are clearly
you did not mean we to be the American
people because your record after four
years shows that you do not really trust
the American people to live their own
lives and carve out their own destinies
by we you must have meant the federal
government if I am mistaken then I wish
you would you would
up the point and clear up the record
because from what I can tell you and
your party do not think the American
people can do anything on their own they
cannot buy a car on their own and they
wouldn't know to buy the right car in
the first place they cannot go to their
local hardware store to buy a light bulb
on their own without we're told
destroying the whole planet they cannot
send their kids to college on their own
they cannot go to a doctor on their own
they cannot save up for and buy a house
on their own and we're still paying for
that one they cannot light or warm
houses on their own they cannot buy
their children's school supplies on
their own or pack their children's
school lunches mr. president according
to you we live in a world in which
fathers no longer know what to tell
their sons to do when their sons are
confronted by a bully at school so you
have a ridiculous anti-bullying summit
and put up a silly website called
stopbullying.gov on that website you
tell young people being picked on not to
bully back mr. president my father
taught me a different lesson he didn't
say not bully back that phrase didn't
make any sense to him he had it all
together different lesson and mr.
president I am guessing that the seals
that took out Osama bin Laden were not
taught by their fathers to not bully
back
I am guessing that the Marines and seals
and soldiers and sailors and airmen of
this great country to say nothing of the
police gave those bullies are right good
drubbing when they were in school but
what is more worrisome is why you as
president of the United States with our
national defense to worry about why you
are inserting yourself as a father is it
because your policies and the policies
of the Democrats over the last 50 years
have left to few fathers and our
families and neighborhoods is it because
bullying now does not mean the
roughhousing we find in the first
chapter of Tom Sawyer but because of
your policies bullying has turned into
gang violence involving guns and knives
and events called drive-bys and curbing
'he's hitherto unknown in this great
country but that have become all too
regular and are by the way celebrated by
the multi-million dollar so-called
musical artists you claim to listen to
and certainly hang out with mr.
president you say are you you're going
to put 100,000 teachers in the schools
across America well that sounds great
but we know by now that these large
promises translate into more
unionization and more school bureaucracy
and not one child in a hundred learning
how to read write and think about good
and beautiful things mr. president can
you point to what has happened in our
schools over the last 60 years when your
party has run them to say this is what
we need more of do we look to the
schools of Illinois and specifically
Chicago where you come from and your
secretary of education comes from in a
state in a city that are run by
Democrats from top to bottom and see a
model of success we do know that
politicians children do not go to these
schools ever rather rather than the 100
thousand teachers you promised to put in
the classrooms let us talk instead about
the millions of parents in both suburb
and city who are pulling their children
out of the schools your associates are
in charge of who are homeschooling both
for the sake of their children's
learning and their moral compass that
has led astray in the schools you have
given us and those who are saving every
dime to have enough to put their
children into private schools or who are
on waiting lists that number in the
thousands to get into charter schools
that offer traditional methods of
teaching your
associates have long ago discarded and
clear rules of right and wrong that you
say can no longer be enforced tell me
mr. president why the other day I met
the parents of a young Hispanic lad in a
charter high school who voluntarily
wears a tie every day and whose teachers
described him as a gentleman tell me why
those parents had to pull him out of his
regular school because they knew he was
going to join a gang but that school was
established by a group of parents this
charter school who were lectured by
their local school board on how damaging
that school would be to the children of
that city and the Charter was only
reluctantly past but the parents whose
children attend that charter school do
not see the damage they see children
coming home happy and full of new in
from new knowledge about old things
every day they see high school kids
debating in class who the best founding
father was they see young ladies crying
at the end of Jane Austen novels
children who were not taught to read and
write well in the school establishment
well well in the school establishment
that you control they see them reading
the Masters Poe Dickinson and
Shakespeare will those be fully
unionized teachers mr. president or do
you want to get into particulars mr.
president you say you have finally
bought better medical brought better
medical care or health insurance or
necessary regulations to the health
profession you're really not very clear
on what you have done nor the doctors or
patients but there was a time in this
country when doctors were not
unknowledgeable out about their patients
and what they could afford and what
treatments they ought to receive I know
that because my grandfather was a doctor
and I used to shell Peas that the
farmers brought him in lieu of cash
payment and the steaks and other produce
of their farms and it was that way all
around the country mr. president you can
read about it in that great American
classic To Kill a Mockingbird which has
great lessons of both about race and
equality but also great lessons about
how civil society and towns and
neighborhoods work together when times
are really hard when in fact politicians
in Washington made those times harder
than they needed to be mr. president do
all these mind-numbing regulations which
are driving experience men and women in
the medical world out of there
profession and causing the best and
brightest to think twice about entering
it or these regulations going to improve
trust between doctor and patient mr.
president you can ask any doctor
particularly any obstetrician about the
high rate of unwed mothers in the
country what is the reason for this
phenomenon could it be that in those
schools we were talking about
bureaucracies at the state level
controlled by your party have mandated
certain of certain form of health
curriculum and we all know that health
is just a code word for drugs and sex in
one state the health class requirements
are called I kid you not sexual
performance standards mr. president
could it be instead of teaching children
for that is what they are how to have
umpteen different ways of safe sex
that's what we call it that we should
teach something to their souls could it
be if we spent more time reading stories
of love and family involving good men
and women the kinds of things that used
to be read in schools instead of being
told where the Norse office is so they
can pick up their condoms if if the
other thing happened could it be true
that these people might have some hope
in this life some hope of happiness and
some knowledge about how to achieve it
mr. president we see the world
differently where you see bigger
government I see lesser people you call
people who think the way i do greedy and
not willing to give up a little more of
their share I see these same people
founding charities and institutions that
make human life worth living and those
people who do go to church and they give
money to their churches to do good in
the neighborhoods to help the people
they know to them a family on hard times
a child who needs some Christian who
needs some Christmas presents when his
father has lost his job is not just a
number is not part of a bureaucratic
caseload in those churches the message
message is taught that man cannot live
by bread alone but what are the various
programs you and your party have offered
over the last 60 years other than the
scraps of bread falling off an ever
bigger government table where have they
worked in what state in what city where
the progressive liberal agenda is in
charge where has it worked
you asked what were for mr. president
were four towns where the only standing
in line is that a family standing in
line to see the feel-good movie of the
year that all the critics will hate
waiting to see the elephants and clowns
in a circus we're not for the monthly
indignity of men and women standing in
line for the so-called benefits you are
the author of mr. president we want to
live in a world where the Boy Scouts do
not become a tool of political
opportunism and while we're on the Boy
Scouts mr. president can you name one
federal program your party has created
in the last 60 years that has done more
to build the character of the young
people in this nation than the Boy
Scouts I shall be waiting for your
answer mr. president you say people who
believe the things I do lack compassion
well let's try an experiment in
compassion imagine your home in your
neighborhood has just been devastated by
a hurricane or other natural disaster as
we see happen in some place in this
country every year you're trying to sort
out through the rubble and wondering
what you and your children will do to
restore your lives back to some order
you're beside yourself with the things
you have lost and then you look up and
see someone coming down the driveway
would you in your heart of hearts
whether that person be some worker from
the Red Cross or the Salvation Army or a
FEMA director I am NOT trying to make a
joke mr. president be honest mr.
president you have been in politics for
a while now in the State House in
Illinois in US Congress and now as
president I would like to give you one
illustration I would like you to give
one illustration one example of a policy
or a position that you have taken that
it said yes to the can-do spirit of the
American people the spirit of Benjamin
Franklin and no to big government just
one we put our faith in different places
you and I and I am NOT talking about
religion you put your faith in an
intrusive government that does more that
does more than what the Founding Fathers
ever intended it to do in the
Constitution the Constitution you swear
to uphold and then start listing a dozen
reasons you do not uphold it but Sir the
faith I have the horse I'm backing in
this race for which the stakes are
nothing less than human freedom and
happiness is the American people
every time thank
thank you thank you I my plane didn't
get into about 2 30 last night we were
delayed for a long time and in Detroit
where I came from so I got sort of
worked out worked up as we were flying
around the airport there must have been
the weather but it any rate thank you
thank you for coming we now have
question time for questions I think and
I'd be happy to answer something yes sir
Oh Mike rejest you're supposed to use
the microphone I agree with your
fulmination but the problem is the
president's not listening to you tyrants
don't listen we listen to them why isn't
someone called out what he what our
current so-called president really is
okay my answer to that is I think those
who are running for office should do
these things and the frustration that I
have and I could I could spin all days
probably you could as well talking about
Reagan but Reagan never looked to
whether a policy was politically viable
or not that was the one rule he had his
governor of california from the very
first day he was in office he looked to
things that were true and therefore he
said things were that were true and as
he said in his inaugural in his in his
farewell address he said you call me the
great communicator and i'll take that
but i always thought that I wasn't a
great communicator it's an i creat i
communicated great things and so my
frustration is with the political class
who listened to some very popular and
well-known people nowadays who tell them
how to massage their message or who
listen to certain some of our friends
and think tanks who adjust this policy
or that policy and that they don't speak
to the heart so I don't think he's
listening to what's going on right now
at the kirby center but I hope somebody
is and I and I hope that politicians or
those who go into politics and may be
better people need to go into politics
in the first place and Reagan said that
time and time again but they need to go
back to true first principles and this
is not true just to politics this is
true of everything so I hope that I
don't know if that answers your question
but that's that's the direction I'm
trying to
move in another question whoever is
doing the mics who chooses yes sir in
speaking of civil society on which
current leaders or leaders coming up on
the horizon do you think are promoting
or could be promoting the the
Renaissance of civil societies you're
describing it yes sir I don't like to
play those games because I'm not a I'm
not a political analyst you know I know
the names that we all know and we see on
the television all the time and I listen
to them and I like some of the things
that they say many of these people are
very young right now and so it'll be a
test to see whether they stick to these
principles a lot of them have come out
of the tea parties and they seem very
impressive but I'm not backing a
particular horse right now at the moment
I think that it's encouraging that there
are young people and I won't say in the
party because it's not a party that I
have an affiliation to but there are
young people in American politics now
who seem determined not just to hone a
message that gets votes but actually to
hone a message that's right yes this
gentleman here thank you I do have a
question but I just wanted to add one
thing to your story about Ben Franklin
sort of proved i am a Ben Franklin fan
one of the reasons as you problem you
may notice that the British wanted his
help in deciding where to put the
lightning rods is because I had so many
warehouses full of gunpowder and when
they got Franklin's help they put the
the lightning rods on those warehouses
in that gunpowder stayed away from being
blown up and several years later in the
mid 1770s a gunpowder was on British
ships on its way to America to help put
down a colonial rebellion so there's
that one irony but my question is and
getting to the earlier question into
your talk about associations and I know
you probably read the book Bowling Alone
so you know he's talking along the same
lines if the federal government is now
all pervasive and we are sort of seeing
now what they are young people kind of a
isolation with their video games and
their computers and their texting and
whatever what do we do to bring back
associations to bring back
that that kind of underlying way that we
got together as people get in small
groups and small towns or whatever and
encourage that other than with just
federal government there any other
things that we can do well that's a
great question I mean I wished a lot of
parents would just say turn off the
television turn off the video games and
too few unfortunately do that the area
that I'm most familiar with is the area
of school formation and on that front I
think there's a lot there's a lot of
hope because the a lot of parents have
figured it out that the schools even in
the very best communities suppose in
Nice communities but nonetheless not
good school districts don't don't have
the schools that they should have and so
these people are getting together and
they're they're reeducation themselves
and the things that they themselves are
not educated in and they're honing up on
the classics and so they're actually
engaging in active civic participation
sometimes in a very heroic way because
they get called all kinds of things by
the school establishment and they have
to take it from you know these people
who denounced them in public meetings
and it's just it's spreading like
wildfire and that that is an important
thing because if you look at these
schools as Franklin did as little
institutions that do two things they
teach self-government in the classroom
because they teach the founding fathers
and they teach moral principles in the
basic sense of moral self-government but
they also are models of how people come
together in order to achieve an end and
they have to they have to be political
in the best sense of the word and that
they're participating any any polis
structure for the for the common good so
that I see is is pretty promising in
other aspects of civil society and
particularly if we were to get into the
issue of culture which is the broad
brush that taints civil society I don't
see as much hope but who knows there are
people out there who think that the one
of the advantages of the internet
revolution is that people like me can
publish books who are not liked by the
New York establishment
I'm not going to put in another plug for
my book but it is about self government
during the Reagan years set in Texas it
involves baseball but I hope that's
helpful at least okay this gentleman
here I want to play a little game of
what if if you had written his speech
and Romney had taken the speech than
delivered at the Republican convention
what would we you surmise would be the
reaction of that David yeah I I'm my
question is what would be the reaction
the next day of the establishment media
what would I say dessert but we had that
experiment right they went berserk all
the time over Reagan Reagan was the most
pilloried man for eight years of his
life that you could ever imagine I was
just a kid then but you know it was
every day it was constant and there was
no alternative media star wars for
example he was laughed out of the house
because of Star Wars the evil empire
speech they thought he was such a
troglodyte for talking about right and
wrong did that ever cost him a vote no
it created the phenomenon known as the
Reagan Democrats Franklin went into
their territory he got Union votes he
got the votes of the young he fought for
the things that we've just declared or
off limits now because we've calculated
it but because of this stupid way of so
many conservative so many liberals and
so many people in between this age group
that age group this occupational group
Reagan didn't hold to any of that which
is why in his inaugural he made that
great statement about that special
interest it's been so long overlooked
the special interests we call the
American people so whether you know my
speech or not I don't know whether
that's the thing you probably have to be
refined a little bit i just wrote it in
one night but i think some good red meat
stuff would have done wonders
particularly in that third debate oh my
gosh did the anchor gave him the perfect
setup why didn't he ask the question why
those men were not protected and
supported why didn't you ask the
question which is the first thing that I
heard when I first heard the news where
are the dead Marines you don't get into
American embassies and consulates in
this world on sep tember 11th as
dangerous as it is without Marines
guarding the whole place and those folks
don't go down with
find nothing I think if he would have
went after him he would have one other
people look at the demographics and say
no but I was disappointed and I think a
lot of people were I mean I don't want
our I don't want this to turn into a
Romney bashing session I mean I think I
think he's a fine man and he tried to
run a very upstanding campaign and and
that i'm not trying to second-guess
anybody but that's my opinion this lady
here thank you what role if any do you
think mainline churches have had in the
degradation of civil society let me see
if I understand what that question means
what role have the Oh mainly I see what
you're saying okay so they're
compromising on certain moral issues
particularly those around sex well the
church has become like any institution
like the school or anything else if you
if you actually trace what goes on at
divinity schools and theology schools
for the most part I don't know as much
about the professor's I know a lot of
good professors and I read a lot we were
serious theologians but I know that a
lot of the people who go into the
ministry and I was told this by my
friend who I I had who taught in a
seminary and his graduate students would
get in there and they would start
reading Luther they'd start reading
calvin and they would ask questions such
as wow these guys are really worked up
about sin did
did did they like have sexual hang-ups
or what what do you say to that I mean
there is a thing called a Bible and
there's a whole variety of theology that
comes after after the Bible so it seems
like me that is the message that you
carry and in the same way that the the
political message ought to be these are
the founding principles and these
actually work and we've shown them to
work it seems like a church is a similar
institution and so compromising with the
with the you know the church is
fundamental mission I I object to but
yeah I I just haven't worked out how
much it actually changes things
politically what I worry more about is
that the right kind of messages aren't
being told the congregation's
particularly in the area of sexuality
and particularly when it regards young
women and I think if somebody just got
up and gave a good story about David or
Adam and Eve that young people would
actually respond to it because they're
not told how to handle their sexuality
who tells him that so that's as best I
can do with that question we have time
for one more question yeah just
following up on that a little bit you
said of Regan that he had faith in
America that he also said Dixon Illinois
was heaven he said I learned standards
and values there and obviously he was a
great believer in the civil society as
you said and in individualism and the
integrity of the individual and so on
but I'm wondering if you could place
then under sort of standards and values
what he religious and faith basis was
including in Dixon or where ever in
Reagan's thought and influence therefore
on his other thoughts religious liberty
and things like that so you're asking me
about Reagan's piety his own personal
piety is his own personal faith and
whether it or not it was basically the
asus for all the other things you were
saying right in other words the values
those are right Christian values that he
learned at first christian church in
dixon right no I I think it is
throughout Reagan speeches I mean you
can scarcely read a Reagan speech that
doesn't have some reference to God he he
wasn't I never found him to be political
as choosing one religion over another
but he broadly embraced religion in this
country and saw its importance for
maintaining a moral standing and and
being in a way that the source of the
rock of truth the other thing that I was
going to say is and I didn't I didn't
put this into the talk but I thought a
lot about it is you know when when you
divide up the lines of who gets to talk
about what and and the Democrats are
happy to talk about anything they talk
about the economy but they'd rather talk
about other stuff they're more
comfortable with that and the
Republicans always seemed really
ham-handed and uncomfortable with that
what very often happens is the one area
where conservative candidates are
comfortable is in talking about religion
because that's what they that's the
local society that they see the most of
they go to church every Sunday and
that's where they see a lot of good
being done in the way of charity and all
kinds of things that's where they see
marriage is taking place but the problem
is that every time a conservative
candidate does that he risked getting
being declared you know an evangelical
right-wing evangelical fanatic and can't
you know keep the different straight
between God and and politics and that
just never seemed to bother Reagan I
mean he just he just said what he wanted
to say and let them howl all they wanted
to I do i do think that there are some
things some issues where candidates need
to be careful about how they express
themselves because I'm sometimes they
speak from what appears to be the basis
of faith but it doesn't seem to me to be
faith at all
and in particular in this last election
these these comments about rape those
just would it was just stupid and and I
don't I don't think there's any place in
the Bible or any church or anything that
that should say that I mean it when you
say something like that it seems to lack
compassion and then when you talk about
the age of the universe and what do you
believe in science and all the rest of
it conservatives sometimes get tangled
up in that too rather than just having a
simple modesty and say you know like
Rubio was just asked well how old is the
earth why didn't you just say go ask a
geologist you know I'm a political man I
nearly failed geology when I was in
school I mean if he would have just
given that answer he wasn't he would not
I don't think he would alienate anybody
in the religious right and he doesn't
give somebody to somebody something to
hang himself with so but what Reagan
based his talking about religion in was
was truth and was were the virtues of
charity and the virtue of modesty
frankly and if they're if there's one
virtue that Reagan had in abundance that
comes straight out of the Bible and it
seems to me that the progressives do not
have at all that is humility and so if
there's one christ-like lesson that
could be taught every election that I
wish politicians would act frankly say
say we have to be humble here because
we're humans and you're trying to do God
like things are you God if you throw
that Mac Adam I I wonder how they would
respond to that so I hope that's helpful
this gentleman says amen so sermons over
thank